presumptive democratic presidential
nominee joe biden says he's close to
choosing a running mate yesterday the
former vice president told reporters in
delaware
he will decide next week ed o'keefe was
there and has the latest from the
campaign trail it was clear tuesday that
joe biden came prepared to answer
questions about senator kamala harris
a photographer caught this image of
biden's notes that mentioned the senator
including lines
like do not hold grudges and great
respect for her
but besides reiterating his august
timeline biden didn't share
any details about who he's favoring i'm
not prepared to say much more than that
instead he focused his attention on the
pandemic sharply criticizing president
trump
he's shown that he can't beat
the pandemic and keep you safe
and spending most of his time detailing
how his economic recovery plan
would address racial inequities my build
back better plan
would make sure families in these
communities are the ones who benefit
from the hundreds of billions of dollars
in federal investment biden's plan would
set aside
30 billion dollars for a small business
opportunity fund to help asian black
latino and native american
business owners and it would aim to have
at least 15 percent of the federal
government's contract spending on goods
and services
be with minority owned firms we also
asked biden what he makes of plans to
reopen schools
and restart pro sports i think that
it there are guidelines
that have to be made much more specific
by the cdc they should let the
scientists
speak that the scientists speak
should there be sports right now though
it's probably not going to be able to
happen
based on based on what the leagues
themselves are saying
now back to that vp pick in addition to
senator harris other names in the mix
include senators tammy duckworth and
elizabeth warren
congresswoman val demings of florida and
karen bass of california
and obama national security adviser
susan rice
gail at this point in a presidential
campaign we're basically left to read
tea leaves as we wait
for the final decision when he was
brandishing there
that's what we call a tea leaf for sure
listen and it's washington's best
guessing game you have any predictions
you know people
he's picking a woman that's what we know
all right
all right o'keefe i knew you'd have the
answer i knew you'd have the answer
thank you sir